Okay.
This is a great review of fractions. But what else can we do with fractions?
With the counting numbers, we can add, subtract, multiply and divide. We can do
the same operations with fractions. You might be asking yourself, what's an
operation. An operation is just something that takes input values and produces
an output value. Like addition, we could have 2 plus 3. 2 and 3 are the inputs,
and I get 5 as the output. Or, I could have 4 times 7. 4 and 7 are my inputs,
and I get 28 as the output. An operation just produces a new value. For now,
we're going to continue working with fractions and look at multiplication. But
we're going to return to our chocolate bars. Here's my one chocolate bar. This
time, I'm going to split up my chocolate bar into pieces. I'm going to find a
fraction of a fraction. So what is 1 3rd of one half of the chocolate bar? Let's
find out. Here's a drawing of a chocolate bar. And now first, I'm going to split
it in half. So I started with 1 bar and now I have half a bar. I want to find 1
3rd of that oine half. So, I need to take this half of a chocolate bar and split
it up into thirds, or three equal pieces. I've split my half into thirds now.
And now I just need 1 3rd of the one half. So this piece right here represents 1
3rd of my one-half. So, I found 1 3rd of one half. It's this shape piece. But,
I'm wondering, what fraction is this piece compared to the original candy bar? I
can split up my original candy bar into the same size pieces as this one. That
will let me see what fraction is this of my candy bar. So visually I can see
that this piece is 1 6ths of my. My candy bar. So let's pair this with some
math. 1 3rd of one half has to be equal to 1 6th but I need to figure out what
did I do to these two fractions. How did I combine them to get 1 6ths? Let's
answer this question with a quiz.